[Music]
in order to have a democracy that
thrives and actually that manages to
stay alive at all you need regular
citizens being able to get good solid
information but as it turns out right
now we are suffering the a lot of
information warfare or a lot of bad
actors both foreign and domestic are
trying to screw things up telling us
things that aren't true causing us to
lose faith in the press in democracy and
our institutions so as far as I could
tell the only constructive way to deal
with that is to support a trustworthy
press and as part of that to support
good research serves trying to figure
out where is the bad stuff coming from
how do you disrupt that how do you stop
it from happening and a lot of those
things are happening now what I'd like
to see is a whole bunch of news outlets
first commit to being trustworthy and
they do that by signing up for the trust
project principals then I'd like to see
them oh now and then have someone serve
as a watchdog maybe via the
International fact-checkers Network
which is basically a network of networks
I would like to see fact checkers in the
network or out submit results that they
find to the emerging database done at
Tech and check where a claim which is
fact checked could be registered in that
manner using a standard term you know
standard database layout I'd like to see
nutrition labels generated by the by the
folks there and as that's beginning to
happen I'd like to see Oh more and more
people work together to create an
ecosystem we're in all these signals of
trustworthiness the trust project stuff
actual fact-checking seeing if people
went ahead and
corrected errors that were made if all
these signals be could be consolidated
and then made available to anyone who
wants them particularly the social media
platforms so there's a lot coming people
are beginning to put into practice the
signals of trustworthy journalism people
are beginning to consolidate them and
the hope is in the near term that the
social media platforms or anyone else
use those signals of trustworthiness
I have also faith in advertisers to use
them because advertisers are finding
that they want to be there ads to be
connected to reporting and other forms
of entertainment which is trustworthy
and in the spirit of trustworthiness so
it is a matter of survival for the
advertising business as well as the
survival of a democracy and the people
pulling together these signals of
trustworthiness are paying big attention
to the questions of advertising and of
journalistic quality they need to do all
this because if they don't do a good job
of it people will trust the
advertisements less and less as they see
they may be connected to untrustworthy
reporting so trustworthy reporting when
you can see that it really is
trustworthy is a big market
differentiator for news outlets but also
for the advertisers who place ads in
those trustworthy outlets I'm very
optimistic about journalism because the
people in the business feel that they
got a really big wake-up call in 2016
they're now doing an increasingly good
job there's a lot of challenges that
remain but people have realized that a
lot needs to be fixed and there's a lot
of a mentum behind fixing things in the
case of people like me who are helping
often with dollars we got to get out of
the way
and stay away that's what the ethics of
funding nonprofit journalism require
[Music]